defense secretary john healey mr healey
good morning to your thoughts first of
all
if i may ask you on how the government
the british government is dealing with
this
well the first priority is to get
safely all british nationals and those
afghans who worked with us
over the years out of kabul and the
government has our full labor support
in doing that the second priority is to
know from the government what's the plan
through the united nations the g7
through nato to
try to
secure the gains over the last 20 years
in afghan society
to ensure that the
international aid keeps flowing to avoid
a humanitarian crisis and to prevent
afghanistan again becoming a haven for
terrorists and
the
british foreign policy and leadership
has gone missing in action uh in recent
weeks and this is the importance of the
recall of parliament there are serious
questions that stuart ramsey was just
saying that we need to know the answers
to
can we do business with the taliban
well the taliban
has now become the government again in
afghanistan it's really important that
individual countries don't leap to
recognize and deal with them uh it's
important that any
uh dealings with the taliban it seems to
me are coordinated internationally
probably for you through the united
nations
buddy we will have to recognize the fact
that the reality now is that
the afghan government with whom we
worked
and we did so much to support including
the support of our troops in afghanistan
over 20 years
has been overrun by the taliban and the
speed and scale
of the taliban advance the
strength of the afghan government and
their forces has been badly
underestimated by
western strategists and it's left us
with this
dire dreadful situation that we've been
seeing unfolding in the last couple of
days
so we can do business with the taliban
internationally every country is going
to have to deal in some way with the
taliban if we want to
try and secure the undertakings we've
given to the afghan people
withdrawing our forces but not walking
away from the country or its people
then this is the government that the
international community is going to need
to deal with but it should be done in a
coordinated way
the uk has a special responsibility to
afghan
and afghan people
and i'd really like to see a great deal
more being said and done by our british
government
to try and lead those efforts to
secure the gains over the last 20 years
and also ensure that
afghanistan doesn't plunge again into a
humanitarian crisis
i think we're already there aren't we
certainly there's an awful lot of people
trying to leave the country as one would
anticipate 20 years ago 41 000 afghan
refugees were allowed to resettle in the
united kingdom one can only imagine it's
going to be more than that this time
should we open our arms to them
this is
really desperate for the afghan people
it isn't just their fearing for their
way of life
many are fearing for their lives
themselves and
really i think when
women civic leaders academics
journalists are
fearing for their lives i think it's
unthinkable and shameful that britain
wouldn't be willing to say we'll look at
offering you safety
canada has already made the commitment
to take 20 000 afghan refugees and i
want to hear on wednesday from the prime
minister that britain is willing to step
up in that way too
and
demonstrate that we demonstrate that we
have our responsibility to the afghan
people and we're not walking away from
them now
do you have a figure in mind
no i want to hear what the government's
got to say and i want to hear that
commitment from the government they're
the ones with the information they're
the ones in the position to make the
decision
but it's part of a
what must be an internationally
coordinated effort that is a real
challenge and test for british
international leadership now on keeping
aid flowing
on dealing with the looming refugee
crisis
on preventing this country returning to
being a safe haven
for terrorism uh and also ensuring that
the taliban are very clear if there are
human rights abuses or atrocities they
will be monitored they will be tracked
there will be severe sanctions
we've got to do everything we can in
this desperate dreadful situation now
to demonstrate that we
can help try to secure the gains that
afghan people have seen over the last 20
years since we first went in in 2001. so
it's tricky isn't it because sanctions
of course hit those hardest that have
got leased um so
of course you'll be discussing that on
wednesday when the house reconvenes for
the day but without a vote i believe at
the end of it just a thought before i
let you go do you have a view on the
foreign secretary being out of the
country while this was um developing do
we all need a holiday or should he have
been at his desk
the problem is not the foreign secretary
and whatever holiday he has and hasn't
had it's the absence of any british
foreign office plan or leadership dating
back particularly to 18 months ago when
trump first signed the agreement with
the taliban to make the commitment to
withdraw we should have been making sure
this was a graduated withdrawal we
should have been trying to make sure
that this reflected the conditions on
the ground we should have been rallying
nato allies to try and ensure that the
afghan people did not feel we were
walking away from their country and we
should have been putting in place
the sort of plans to ensure that uh
aid can keep flowing and that we can now
deal with the refugees that may well
come from this crisis